this is a production of cornell
university
thank you for inviting me and as you can
see from my background i'm not a soil
scientist
i study atmospheric chemistry and
climate
but for better worse sometimes one has
to cross disciplinary boundaries
and to see the problem solved in other
words to look at ammonia emissions on a
global scale and a comprehensive earth
system model there was no soil scientist
or biogeochemist or anyone that really
wanted to address this problem on global
scales and
so um
here i am
um before i begin i should acknowledge
stuart riddick so stuart was a postdoc
here he later left for university of
cambridge so he initially formulated
much of this model
and
um
and he formulated its structure
and also dan ward who's sitting in the
audience today he's done a lot of work
since stuart left getting the model in
shape
and um understanding how it behaves okay
so both both stuart and dan
did a lot of the actual work on the on
this on this project
so before i begin i thought i should
um
let's hear my questions that i'm going
to address in this research so they're
probably different than
many of the talks you've heard in this
um in the seminar series and i work on
the global scale
and i'm interested in climate
so the large scale questions is how do
fertilizer manure ammonia missions
change the climate and how will climate
impact these emissions
how do these emissions modify the
nitrogen cascade and how do the
emissions change global pollution in
health so again i'm interested in the
global scale and most of the work i do
is in model simulations it's not it's
not in the laboratory it's not
experimental in that sense
so this is a
way it's a picture of paris march 14
2014
and this pollution event was attributed
to springtime fertilization it was very
hot at that time in paris it's about the
springtime when people applied their
fertilizer
and it pretty much shut down the city
for a week they cars could only drive on
on even or odd days public
transportation was free they decreased
the driving speed limit
trucks were routed around the city so a
lot of this was um has been blamed on
fertilization and ammonia emissions
okay so after introduction i'm going to
talk about the model i'm going to talk
about some of the nitty-gritty
get the results and and then conclusions
so for the background as
i'm sure many of you are
aware
that the um
nitrogen input into the
earth system has increased dramatically
in the um 20th century and it's
increased
really since um haber in bosch
um invented the process for
making ammonia fertilizer out of out of
out of atmospheric nitrogen
okay and so one can see this increase
especially here
after about 1940
and this increase has been thought to
contribute to the large population
increase over the 20th century
and incidentally as i i read a little
bit about haber haber was also not only
invented nitrogen
this process the but he also is known as
the um father of chemical warfare invent
a lot of chemical weapons so he he has
he's an interesting character with um
pluses for humanity and
definitely some minuses
okay so what's going to happen in the in
the future
and in the future as a population
increase
the feeling is that
um
the demand for nitrogen is also going to
increase and so this shows a number of
scenarios for nitrogen fertilizer
consumption so this is nsaid 2100
and these scenarios are driven by
population growth shown here in red
biofuels shown in green
um
and then what decreasing the emissions
is um efficiency and agriculture
food equity is increasing so we don't
quite know what's going to happen in the
future but
um
and this is so these are the type of
scenarios that are used in climate
models this is how the um how the
climate models work to predict the
future
is there's likely going to be an
increase in
nitrogen fertilizer consumption
and if you look
in what's input into most climate models
the
ammonia emissions are like this
reflecting this increase
in in in nitrogen but this neglects the
impact of climate on the emissions so
ammonia emissions are very sensitive to
climate if you
add the impact of climate
then my guess that the ammonia emissions
increase by almost a factor of two
so this impact of agriculture and the
increase of nitrogen emissions
is quite a bit different than what one
expects from
industry and cars and here
almost all the scenarios expect the
other component are the main component
of nitrogen input into the system to
decrease
and this is because already industrial
countries have decreased the amount of
nox emitted into the air
for air pollution regions and it's
expected that other countries too for
example china
will also follow along suit and decrease
their emissions of knocks into the
atmosphere so in the future
fertilizer is likely to increase ammonia
emissions due to fertilizer like likely
to increase
and nox emissions are likely to decrease
ice acid current current thinking
so this is a
figure of the
nitrogen cascade
and nitrogen is essentially put into the
system
largely into the farms in terms of
fertilizer it's also manure here
and in terms of combustion and this is
mostly in terms of nox
okay so the nitrogen so the ammonia
emissions from the farms are estimated
to be about 40 teragrams per year
the nitrogen ammonia is evaporated off
from the farms and then it's cascaded
down in the nitrogen cascade and it
lands on forests natural ecosystems etc
as you go down so to understand the
nitrogen cascade to be able to simulate
it you have to get these nitrogen
ammonia emissions correct
from the farm and one can see that there
are of greater importance than the
combustion emissions
and they're meant to increase in the
future whereas these are meant to
decrease so getting these
getting pneumonia emissions correct it's
important part of being able to simulate
the future nitrogen cascade
what does nitrogen do to climate
so
in this figure here i show the radiative
forcing of various species on the
climate so this is essentially you put
these species into the atmosphere and
you look at the change in energy balance
at the earth's
surface due to these species
and one can see that the
change in energy balance from
pre-industrial to 2011 it's estimated to
be about 2.3 watts per meter squared on
the earth's surface according to this
diagram
now this is known as a radiator forcing
where does nitrogen come into this
nitrogen is a form of fertilizer
and
it's estimated that because the emission
nitrogen emissions have increased that
more co2 has been uptaken by the
atmosphere and so this has changed a
radiative forcing by between five and
ten percent
and to all emissions associated with
fertilizer use exchange to radiate
forcing by about 0.17
nox emissions
through his atmospheric chemistry
decreases methane and increases ozone
associate changes in atmospheric forcing
and then pneumonia emissions itself
ammonia readily forms an aerosol in the
atmosphere aerosols tend to be
reflective and this is active to cool
the earth's surface
so the nitrogen emissions have a lot of
climate effects from warming
to cooling
and probably one of the most important
impacts
is in the aerosols aerosols are
particulates in the air
that um
that essentially cool the earth
and if you look at various various years
so this goes from 2000 to 2100 this is
from
simulation
and
it's projected that by 2100 this yellow
yellow line here which is ammonia
nitrate emissions
ammonium nitrate aerosols will be
the dominant aerosol species so right
now the dominant species is sulfur
it's projected that sulfur will decrease
as the air is cleaned up over
china and other regions
and that ammonia nitrates will become
the dominant aerosol type which acts to
cool which acts to cool the earth
with nitric acid
okay so
in the beginning at the top was input of
of ammonium emissions into an earth
system model
and it could be that some of you um
um are not really familiar with what we
mean by nurse system model so here's
kind of a timeline of how they're
developed
so in um 1896
1900 using hand calculations arrhenius
predicted five to six degree warming for
double co2
and then it waited almost a century
until general circulation models were
able to include double co2
and the difference between a hand
calculation in the
general circulation model large amount
of the of the earth and
an ocean was they allowed feedback due
to water vapor and clouds although
generally these models got about the
same result as arenas got by by hand
and then later on
okay you can predict the climate of the
um 20th century until you allow for the
cooling due to aerosol scattering these
were included in the late 1990s into
these models
and then around the early 2000s the
carbon cycle was incorporated because if
you add co2 to the atmosphere
it's taken up about half of it's taken
up by the ocean and the land
and so this allows if you want to
include a transient response if you want
to simulate the climate from the from
now into um
2100 you need to incorporate carbon
cycle
and if you incorporate a carbon cycle
you need nitrogen
and but nitrogen emissions were
generally not simulated and ammonia
missions were generally not simulated in
these models which is where this study
comes in
okay
so now i'm going to start talking about
the ammonia emission model in the middle
of um in the middle of a
earth system model their system model is
essentially
it's a numerical model it's formulated
as a number of grid squares
like here so they range in the
horizontal and in the vertical
and each square here each of these
square squares we have a model a
parameterization that simulates ammonia
emissions okay
so that's where so this is how it fits
in into this large scale model
and these are the questions
i remind you of the questions i want to
address from the beginning and these are
global questions how does ammonia
missions influence climate
so the idea is to take a essential
process level model by extend it to
global scales
and to do this we have to
simplify local details to a notable
global simulation so we can put all the
details in this kind of model many of
the details are not available globally
it's very hard to get details of
crop type soil type etc
fertilizer day etc globally
and the highly complex regional models
are not are pro
appropriate for global simulations
because the global simulations we're
simulating many things for simulating
the ocean the atmosphere
aerosols etc so we have to
simplify the model
we want to base this type of model in
physics and chemistry to the extent
possible
um because things are based on imperial
parameterizations
and won't be sensitive to
changes in temperatures changes in
precipitation
so so
if we base on basic physics and
chemistry then we think we can
incorporate the changes due to
precipitation and changes in temperature
modeling is an iterative procedure i
think it's important to remember that
i've talked about modeling here at
cornell and many times people so it's
too complicated how can you simulate
that forget it
and and
the thing to recognize is that
okay if you don't simulate it it's not
going to be in there so you can simulate
it
to zeroth order and you have some idea
of how it's going and you can improve it
so it's good to start somewhere
and so i'm interested in is examining
the response of the emissions to forcing
changes in climate temperature
precipitation eventually changes in
management
processes okay incidentally if anyone
has any questions ask me um as they go
i'd just like to contrast the model i'm
going to present with a standard model
so to most ammonia emissions in global
models are based on emission factors
so for example you take the
dairy cattle you take the kilogram
nitrogen per head per year
you multiply it by the
ammonia
loss and you get a number and that's why
you stick as your emissions in the model
and traditionally these have been split
into one region and two into two
different regions depending on whether
the agricultural practices were relevant
for developed countries or developing
countries so the standard type of models
people have used to predict global
nitrogen global ammonia emissions have
not included any temperature
or
dependence on temperature or rainfall
so what we do
is we take a fertilizer amount or manure
amount and we know this fairly well
there have been some studies that
published in nitrogen and fertilizer
nitrogen and manure globally
and we take this amount
and we feed it in
into a model for
fertilizer manure
and then this and then it can go
three ways
the nitrogen in there can go to wash off
if it rains
it can go into emissions and the
emissions depend on the meteorology they
depend on the wind speed and the
temperature and the um surface roughness
so they depend on the boundary
turbulence
and
temperature
or
the emission or the nitrogen
incorporated into fertilizer manure can
go into
the land model which is another part of
this larger system model and within the
land model the nitrogen is apportioned
to vegetation
to soil organic matter
it goes up and it denitrifies
it can go into leaching runoff
it can go into fires etc okay so this is
a base model
that's already incorporated and we're
adding this parameterization on top of
it
then we need another important thing in
these large scale models is to conserve
carbon and nitrogen so when you add
fertilizer this is new nitrogen created
so
you don't have to worry about that but
from in the work manure comes from
nitrogen that's eaten from the plants
so you have cows eat plants
they
excrete manure
and then you have to have then you have
to um take the um carbon and nitrogen
out of the plants
to make them ignore so these type of
models is very important to conserve
carbon and nitrogen because you want to
look at how these
how the budgets change
okay this is um
this is a cow for stuart stewart
scottish so i think is a scottish cow
so
what we've done if we have a
pool
of
ammonic nitrogen here
as i said this can wash off it can go to
gas
or it can go into the land model to the
nitrogen pools here
fertilizer goes into this pool
as does
um manure
and manure is divided into three
separate pools depending on how fast
it's broken down
by
bacteria
okay and then again there's a cycle from
the land model back to the plants to
conserve the carbon and nitrogen from
from the manure
tan
total and molnenko nitrogen
okay
so for fertilizer it goes into a pool
so you add the fertilizer to this pool
this quickly decays it depends on the
temperature how fast it decays
and it goes into tan pool for simplicity
we only apply the fertilizer towards the
beginning of the growing season
when planting conditions for corn are
met
and this is determined from meteorology
so if the growing so if it gets warmer
in the spring
this this fertilization application will
occur warmer or warm years you'll hear a
different time than cold years
and throughout we don't consider
agricultural practices in the models so
agriculture management is going to have
to be added on at a later stage
okay
manure
as i said it goes into three different
pools
this is a tan pool here these pools
these available resistant unavailable
decay at different at different rates
they break down at different weight
rates depending on temperature so one
day for this available pool
much longer for this resistant pool and
this unavailable pole essentially gets
incorporated into the soils
we assume the manure is spread on the
fields continually
throughout the year and again this is a
place where we decided not to consider
agricultural practices
by putting on the fields a few times or
keeping the cattle in stockyards etc we
just assumed it was spread continually
onto the fields
okay and then the tan pool what goes on
in here
we essentially have an equation for the
ammonia gas
that's an equilibrium within a water
solution
within this pool
so the gas depends on the amount of n in
this pool
and then there's some rate constants
below it depends on
on the ph and some henry's law rate
constants as given here
and it depends on the amount of water in
the pool so we have to predict the
amount of water also in the scan pool
and the rate equations are such that the
gas
the amount of gas emitted
increases exponentially with temperature
so there's an exponential temperature
increase here as uh as this as this
warms it becomes less soluble to ammonia
and there's more ammonia gas sitting
right on the boundary of the pool
okay
oops
let's do this emissions
our century proportional
to the amount of gas sitting on the
boundary of the tan pool minus the
amount in the atmosphere divided by some
resistances
okay and then this we take the wash off
from the global news model
run off from the tan pool
okay and then there's um
conversion from the tan pool to the soil
pool which we simply
account for as diffusion either of
ammonium or nitrate and it has different
diffusion rates
okay so i think i talked about these
assumptions
let's go on to the
results
so this is a distribution from potter
head off 2010
of nitrogen
from manure and nitrogen from
fertilizer
and
one can see for both menu and fertilizer
they are um
europe
india china
midwest here are
our
areas of heavy
application and then from manure it
brings in a number of other areas brazil
here
sub-saharan africa
across this region here
okay so this is used as input to the
model
and then we see what then we see what
happens
and so we predict nitrogen emissions
um this is the 10-year average in the
model
this is from manure this is from
fertilizer
and again for the nitrogen emissions you
can see these hot spots over india
and china
you can see hot spots here over
on this part of africa
india etc and this is because
the emissions increase exponentially
with temperature so you warm temperature
you get more fraction of the amount of
the tan pool that evaporates as
emissions
yeah are these emissions from the
surface
these are from the
surface but the units are kilograms per
year per hectare
right so they're
surface emissions per unit area per year
okay so
um yeah so what we do is we account for
a canopy capture of the emissions so
once we once we put the once we so this
is we're looking at the emissions from
the land model once we connect it to the
atmosphere then we'll be able to
simulate how much goes up and how much
goes down so you so you're right there's
a bi-directional flux of ammonia that's
very hard to simulate so here we assume
some canopy capture from some
numbers in the literature but that is
one of the assumptions that will be
changed
so here
again you can see in these
over india
sub-saharan africa where it's warm a
large percentage of the
emit a large percentage of the ammonia
and the emissions are released
as ammonia gas into the
into the atmosphere
okay
okay
the u.s to be much higher in
okay well i mean there are two things in
your question one is um the database
i mean maybe
i mean this is one of the best databases
available and what they did is they to
combine this they took
um
they counted animals in each country and
they took information from fao
etc
and so this is the best as far as i know
um
database for fertilizer and animals now
maybe it might not be correct i i i
don't know but this is i mean this is
exactly one of the problems in trying to
apply these things globally is that we
just don't have that good data
okay
okay so evaluation
how do we how do we do i want to um
go over this pretty quickly
um because here i'm showing some
evaluations from previous versions of
the model though i expect it will be
similar in these in this in this current
version
and this shows
manure emissions versus
model versus measurement
r square is .84
annual the average amount percent
evaporation changes from five to ninety
ninety percent and one can tell this
correlation between the model and
measurements is largely driven by this
change in temperature when temperatures
high you get
large emissions of ammonia might be
expected
correlation with um
fertilizer is not as good but still
significant
and here again it's probably driven by
temperature we've looked at different
um emissions some fertilizer different
latitudes
okay i should say um
as this has already been brought up
valuing on the emissions are
very difficult
the concentrations are not well
characterized
missions are bi-directional they can be
up and down depending on the
time of day
ground-based measurements are
challenging they're highly dependent on
meteorology
and the emissions are captured by the
canopy and describe a rather complex
resistance model so it's a is is
when you make a model you have to
evaluate it but evaluation here is um is
is challenging
so another way to evaluate a model is to
compare it against
other emission inventories
so in each of these diagrams is the is
our emission inventory
this is the most recent one which has
come from a data inversion
it's another one which is
has developed within the last four years
and this is a standard one used by
global atmospheric fathers
these are split between manure
and fertilization emissions
we can see that we our emission
inventory is about all of them in fact
are about the same
about the same amount of nitrogen
are split between
fur emissions ammonia emissions from
fertilizer and manure
is a little bit different than these two
we
show more fertilizer less manure
so it's between this one and this one by
edgar so we write like right between
i should say that all these inventories
here it's a great deal of uncertainty on
these on these global numbers
if we can look at different regions
our u.s emissions so this is
us us and us
china notice that the scale is one as
212.
u.s and europe is
to 4.5
so all of the all the emission
inventories predict higher emissions in
china that even though then over the u.s
and
and europe
our emissions over the u.s are higher
than these other inventories largely
because we have larger fertilizer
emissions
same with um in over europe
where
where our
manure emissions are a little bit lower
than some of these obvious
but generally considering
the um what we're trying to do in this
model
um
we're pretty pleased with with with
these results we're capturing the um
emissions
within the range of the other emission
inventories where there's a great deal
fair also
yes we do
yeah
yes
yeah so we assume fifty percent of the
nitrogen is from year and fifty percent
from in newark and then the manure piles
have different rates of breakdown
okay so um oops
okay so once the manure is in this tan
pool then there are different ways it
can go it can volatilize to the
atmosphere has competed so
if it's washed out a lot it won't fall
to lies as much
and so this shows the runoff from manure
and runoff from fertilizer
one can see the runoff in these models
again as concentrated as one might
expect in
regions of high application and in moist
regions
eastern u.s europe china and india shown
here
fertilizer manure and that's this
percent runoff so again as these regions
um
china
europe has quite a high percent eastern
us
in this region and over
brazil in both
fertilizer and and
manure so this is one of the things
that
we can use this model to do is that in
the future as precipitation changes
presumably these patterns of manure loss
due to runoff will also also change in
the
future yeah so this is surface runoff
there will be additional runoff
from leaching once it gets once the
nitrogen from there goes into soil so it
can be run off first but this is this is
surf deep
no no it's not yeah
so in a um in another work again this is
preliminary results it's uh from cindy
nevison and all and what she's doing
it's looking at observed river export of
nitrogen
from rivers around the world
and we can also calculate this quantity
in in the model i mean the calculation
is indirect we need to know how the
rivers run how much of the nitrogen in
the rivers is denitrified but one can
see
it's a way of bounding
is another way of constraining these
type of parameterizations in earth
system models by looking at the runoff
in
in rivers which sure is pretty good data
global fate of applied nitrogen
fertilizer
the emissions are
globally just under
25
the
runoff is a little bit higher
and most of it goes into the
soil
for the manure because the manure is
applied slowly throughout the years not
applied as quickly
you see there's less ammonia emissions
less runoff and more gets into the more
it gets into the soil
okay one looks at developing countries
or
developed countries
developing countries tend to occur where
it's
warmer
and
and you can see that in
developing developing countries that the
emissions ammonia emissions
generally are higher than in these
developed countries this is global
us
europe
india china
so you can see europe there's quite a in
these calculations there's quite a bit
high ammonia emission so this this may
have to do partly with when we apply the
fertilizer
yeah this is largely temperature
so we assume the so it does have a
significance
but
we assume so far it's seven okay because
um
stewart's assured me that the ph of
manure is about seven
and a lot of soils are buffered to be
about ph of seven but that is a i mean
it is definitely affected by soil ph
that we haven't incorporated that that's
a good question
well the losses implies
most of the nitrogen put up that implies
that's where the end phase of the
nitrogen from manure fertilizers the
soil organic matter okay but it doesn't
mean it's increasing because so it can
be lost from the soils either by
leaching by denitrification
by forest fires by other beans okay
so it's not and then it's not a yearly
increase it just it's just where is it
going once it's in the manure
that's right yes
yeah this green here is essentially
leaving our model and then it can go
into plants it can be leached out a
number of other
fates okay
okay and then one advantage of models is
you can see what's happened
over the last
um 150 years
and this is the case for
global manure this amount applied
this is the amount going into soils
runoff
and into emissions
and so you can see over over time that
the amount going into soil has decreased
as the amount going into emissions and
runoff has increased over the last
percentage-wise over 150 years
for fertilizer we get quite a bit
different picture fertilizers added all
at once
and in the beginning when very low
amounts of fertilizer added
these calculations suggest that only a
little bit
most of it was incorporated into the
into the soils
but as much larger quantities were added
very quickly
that less could be incorporated into
soils and larger percentages were going
into the air as ammonium
as ammonia or into runoff
um
sensitivities we've looked at
at some of them i think in the interest
of time
i won't go over these
i want to briefly review future work
obviously
agriculture management practices are
important and can impact the emissions
fertilization dates spreading practices
feed yards
and this is a
view of
saturn at all how one should do climate
dependent ammonia missions
some of them should be on to the fields
as we did some of it should be applied
as manure where you might use a
parametrization like ours
some of the um some of it goes into
unidirectional emissions due to feedlots
and these should probably be
parameterized differently because this
isn't a controlled environment they're
not they're not immediately sensitive to
rainfall
or
the temperature outside and these can be
computed using
emission factors okay so there could be
quite a bit of work
adding this to
adding more management practices and
even future management practices into
such a model to see how emissions might
change as a function of of climate
obviously once we get the um
once we get the emissions into the
atmosphere then we can see what the
atmosphere does and in the atmosphere
once we do that there are a lot
many many ways to um
the model many more ways to evaluate it
can evaluate against atmospheric
measurements
against satellite data against
wet deposition against aerosol data etc
and we're eager to look at how emissions
will change in the changing world as the
amount of manure and fertilizer probably
increases as as
management practices change
and as the climate as the climate
changes
okay so the
conclusion um
ammonia is poorly modeled in earth
system models and i hope i made the case
that
there is a
importance in being able to incorporate
it into in these models to look at the
impact of ammonia and climate but also
important as there's an importance of
looking at the impact of climate and
ammonia emissions
missions are expected to increase as the
population grows
implications for nitrogen cascade for
formation of aerosols and there's
implications which i didn't talk about
for global pollution and health
talked about global dependent
climate-dependent global parametrization
of the emissions
responsive to temperature precipitation
it has the ability to conserve nitrogen
carbon
and
suggest strong geographical and diurnal
temperature dependence
um so these i talked about for these are
first steps
um and you can obviously there many
improvements possible
and then there are numerous applications
they're understanding role of nitrogen
as climate changes
so i um thank you for your attention
i would um if any of you have feedback i
would very much appreciate it as i said
i'm not so a scientist but i would very
much appreciate any feedback from people
who are in the field or know
how this type of parametrization could
be improved
and
i'm going to have to run off to class in
just a few minutes but thanks for your
attention
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu